you take forever different I do now I'm
gonna be that person we've been friends
for seven years living together for five
we've been friends since freshman year
of high school little over ten years
today we're going to start a clothing
swap for a week which is really excited
cuz I think she dresses better than me
so I'm so nervous I think I'm gonna hate
this I feel like our styles are really
different we used to have the same
wardrobe in college basically my sense
of style has not changed at all and when
this has gotten way more fashionable I'm
very much about being able to grab
whatever I want out of my wardrobe or
just like slap it together he's not
afraid of like mixing print which I'm
really excited about my expectation for
this week is I kind of feel like I might
dress how I like do when I have a cold I
feel like she's much better at being
like a woman than I am so I feel like
I'm gonna be much more like and like
touch with my feminine wiles so excited
to like dress feels like a doll look at
all the clothes into has picked out for
me it is crazy and this isn't even all
of them this is a very bright color
it's very sheer my midriff is otherwise
bare with a very thin sheet of fabric
between me and the elements I feel like
it looks like I only have like five
minutes to be ready my grandma and my
mom everybody who's been saying you look
so cute today
everybody's even saying actually that I
look like I've lost weight I wore the
dress as I'm trying to do without just
showing you boobs I got the most
compliment on my outfit since Halloween
this is the first day of be wearing
Linda's clothes at work and I'm kind of
nervous I feel like my butt is hanging
out cuz I've never wear leggings as
pants we'll see what my co-workers think
it okay it doesn't look bad on her it
just it looks like Linda you loved me so
I'm going on a date I am comfortable I
don't quite remember why I hated on jean
so much I mean I do have to say I would
probably promote me in these clothes
rather than if I was wearing my clothes
I literally never want a crop top before
keep wanting like tuck it in or pull it
down no no her lair game is strong but
um I never layer stuff like this I just
feel like parole constricted so I did
not vlog yesterday but you'll see a
photo hopefully of what I wore yesterday
I felt like such a woman like whoa I
realized one of the reasons that I don't
usually wear vests is that I'm very
self-conscious about my upper arms which
I'm starting to realize was really
stupid vests are really great because
they cover your boobs you don't have to
wear like a real bra appreciating my
silhouette more than I usually do cuz I
have to wear a real bra instead of
sports right on fist I'm wearing my
favorite Sarah sweater this is like one
of the ones I was like ooh I can't wait
I mean I've never paid attention to like
what I wear so much in a week it's kind
of exhausting I'm starting to get a lot
more comfortable in someone else's
clothes literally and figuratively the
first day you were making this face the
whole time but like I feel like you're
starting to really rock it and get your
swagger on I'm feeling myself in this
outfit feelin myself I feel bad for what
I said previously I learned that classic
fashion makes me much happier than I
thought it would it was really funny
because she looks better in all my
clothes than I did it's a lot more color
than I would ever wear feel like I
learned how to be braver with fashion
I was scared of like crop tops and flowy
things before her sweater game is like
next level I got my top stock I had to
cover it definitely took less time to
get ready which was great at the
beginning I was so excited as a week
went on I was like I just want my
clothes back on the top like literally
every outfit you picked out for me had
at least one element that made me really
uncomfortable at first by the end of the
week though I was definitely feeling a
lot more comfortable and I was just like
yeah whatever it'll be fine what would
be awesome is if we could share clothes
all the time now we've both decided that
when we shop we have to go together if
Linda was gonna dress me every morning
then yeah sure I would like later but
don't no no no I like this one this
one's nice I love this on you there's a
lot for my boobs
I just keep checking out your chest I'm
glad you brought it up because I didn't
want to be creepy but